hey guys welcome to 3 minutes or less
I'm your host Ryan Wright third week of
July 2015 movie news here we go writers
John Francis Daley and Jonathan
Goldstein Lauren talks to helm the new
spider-man screenplay the writers
previously wrote horrible bosses and the
incredible Burt Wonderstone me in the
new spider-man will be a decent
borderline mediocre yet perverted comedy
director of district nine Neill Blomkamp
takes to his Instagram once more he
showing off new concept art of alien 5
it shows the return of hicks and
sigourney weaver's ripley what time i
had sex with a girl named michelle lee i
can tell you i ripped lee [ __ ] Stanley
confirms that he'll be making a cameo in
the next x-men movie saying it's a
different type of cameo rumor has it
that I'll revolve around the other
spin-off comic sex men involving a
gangbang with Stanley Resident Evil the
final chapter is about to start filming
this is exactly what fans of the video
game and movies I've been waiting for
Disney announces live-action prequel to
Aladdin called genies jeez will be
written by the guys who brought you
Freddy vs. Jason and friday the 13th
remake what really why Michael Cera will
voice the role of Robin into lego batman
movie so get ready for an uncomfortable
awkward yet charming Robin who will
probably still get some Batgirl Lego
[ __ ] in the end director of mama Andy
muschietti isn't talks to helm the
remake of it there is a time where you
would say did you do it referring to
sexual intercourse after seeing this
picture of the clown I changed my mind
and I will do it with the clown you
imagine those teeth giving you a [ __ ]
all right guys let's it for my movie
news of the week if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine periscope social
networks plugs here and you can catch my
videos on Latino Review com a site
dedicated to those of the likes of
Michael Pena